Let me be crystal clear right now, Jesus was in American kid.
And how I know he wasn't American kid is cause he put the Atlantic ocean between
us and the bad guys or else we wouldn't have been able to win world war II and
hail Hitler would be singing off,
would be praised all through the U S but Jesus wasn't American kid. So he said,
you know what, dad, let's put the Atlanta go in between America,
the good guys and Germany, the bad guys. And that's why we won world war II.
And that's why Jesus Christ himself is now just encompassed in the body
of a bald Eagle. And that's why he's our national bird.
And that's why aren't the national flag is red, white, and blue,
because make no mistake. Jesus Christ was a white kid.
This was brought to you by the opinions.
Well here, when you hire an Italian plumber. Wow.
I didn't know you were filming. Yay.